people are always stunned to learn and
that we have a rehearsal before every
show because I think our show maybe it's
a strength maybe it's weakness I don't
want to say but we're very relaxed that
yeah thing can happen yes all right
well several of us noticed something
during rehearsal yesterday this is
absolutely real we didn't make this up
and we checked and sure enough a camera
happened to be rolling on this and then
this happened take a look
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no no I know that it's a back scratcher
when people use those they just scratch
their back you're doing surgery on
vertebrae what is wrong what do you want
you back there for so long I had a
scratch yeah but you're like a bear
against a tree in the woman you're just
I've done that yeah I didn't ask you
about your fetish okay do you always
have the back scratcher back there
behind them ready to go and just in case
I'm just sure it's something wrong with
him
okay so we found that we were looking at
it and we were laughing yeah and then
someone noticed something that took
place a few minutes later that we also
happen to have on tape the band started
rehearsing a song so everyone in the
band is busy playing a song in the
corner I'm playing with them and we're
rehearsing this number again this is
real
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you're such a weird guy that no
one else in the band even notice it
Richie you should get a back scratcher
maraca
[Applause]
all right we just wanted you to let you
know how crazily dysfunctional we all
are by jeans how itchy lebombo and
that's you the bomb is we'll take a
little break we come back Zack
[Applause]
you